-Guys, it's time
for our latest installment
of "Tonight Show" polls.
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show" polls ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love -- I love these --
I love these
because they're informative and
I love polls and I love math.
-Yeah.
-And I just want to get
to know the the world.
-What people think, yeah.
-Yeah, Americans, New Yorkers,
anything.
I just love -- I'm interested.
-Wow.
-So that's why we do
the "Tonight Show" polls.
-Very scientific.
-Yeah, but they're
fun questions.
They're very, very interesting.
Everyone wants to know
about these polls.
The first poll says,
"What is your favorite sport?"
-Wow.
-40% said, "Football."
-Whoa.
-30% said, "Basketball."
20% said, "Baseball."
8% said, "Formula 1."
2% said, "Depends on which one
Taylor shows up at."
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Their favorite sport.
-Favorite, favorite.
-Good sport.
This next poll said,
"What is the best way
to get out of a costume party?"
-Oh.
20% said, "Say you're sick."
20% said,
"Say you're out of town."
60% said, "Say your dressed
as the Speaker of the House
and just don't show up."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Great costume.
-Great costume.
This next poll asked, "What is
the scariest thing ever?"
-Ooh.
-Baby boomers said,
"The cost of healthcare."
[ Laughter ]
Gen X said, "Serial killers."
Millennials said, "Zombies."
Gen Z said,
"Getting a phone call."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ohhh!
-"Dude, I'm freaking out, man!
No!"
-"Coming from inside my phone!"
-"Aaah!"
[ Laughter ]
Next poll asked,
"What's your favorite cheese?"
-Oh, I love cheese.
-25% said Cheddar.
25% said Gouda.
25% said Itz.
-Oh!
-25% said balls.
-Oh! Ew.
Balls.
-Yeah.
Next poll said...
-That go in a cheese sack?
-..."Why did you move in
with your partner?"
That's a cheese head?
-Yeah.
[ Rim shot, chord plays ]
Next poll asks, "Why did you
move in with your partner?"
10% said, "It's convenient."
20% said, "We plan
on getting married."
70% said, "Because Netflix
won't let you share passwords
anymore."
"That's why we're together."
-Come on, true love.
-This next poll asked,
"How do you feel right now?"
20% said, "Eh."
20% said, "Meh."
60% said, "Bleh."
[ Applause ]
Next poll asked,
"What do you do all day?"
20% said, "Slay."
20% said, "Be cray."
60% said, "Hey,
you just did that joke
and it wasn't funny
the first time."
[ Rim shot, chord plays ]
-What?
Wait. What? What?
-"Eh," "Meh," "Bleh."
They heard it, yeah.
-They consider those
similar jokes.
-Yeah, similar jokes.
-A rhyme joke.
-This last one asks, "What is
the best part of Halloween?"
10% said, "Horror movies."
10% said, "Haunted houses."
10% said, "Spooky costumes."
70% said, "The fact CVS already
has their
Christmas displays up."
There you go.
That's all the time we have
for "Tonight Show" polls.